pourquoi me remettre les pendules à
l'heure et prégnant que ça reste un
divertissement et les points chauds et
pas seulement des insultes que les
candidats ressources et des menaces de
mort c'est grave c'est j'arrive en bas
de chez toi je te tue ou plein de choses
comme ça
donc moi je dis juste bravo à denis
brogniart les défenses et qui lors d'y
aller mais calmez vous enfin il les
défend beaucoup sur twitter et ça se
voit que ses protégés sacool web un jury
à toute façon il ya un vrai dépôt de
plainte officielle de la société de
production et 45 j'avais déjà reçu des
insultes vous seriez des menaces de mort
dont les missions des ménages des
menaces de propos de mekhissi près ce
nom les gens m'aimaient bien non mais
ici ici oui il ya encore des tas de
période quand on à traiter certains
sujets oui il ya eu des menaces de mort
oui bien sûr non seulement surveiller
votre famille originaire de mort nommé
mais des insultes c'est normal mais
voilà j'en ai marre non ah oui beaucoup
dernièrement là quand on avait parlé des
essais sur elle si vous savez des essais
cliniques que je m'étais mal fait
comprendre certainement sur les essais
qu'on devait faire en afrique gmail est
pris à tondre audacieux je peux
comprendre les assauts je les reçois
comme les compliments on se comprend
très bien j'essaie de m'excuser quand je
peux mais je comprends qu'il ya des
choses s'avèrent mais après faut pas
prendre ça trop au premier degré parce
que les menaces sont jamais suivies
d'effets on dit toujours qu un chien qui
aboie ne mord pas si c'est jean-françois
dangereux ne préviennent pas les gens
qui me sont très dangereux mais ne
préviennent pas t'inquiète pas un mec
qui dit je te tape il tape a déjà eu
moi je la seule fois que d'abord ils
sont gentils les gens en général la
seule fois que j'ai reçu des insultes
c'est quand j'avais 10 ou les voit une
émission où j'avais de toute façon moi
si ça se trouve au mois de juin je
rembourse mali et dès que j'ai fini je
m'en vais j'arrête je vous aviez dit
ouais tu peux pas dire ça tu manques de
respect aux téléspectateurs alors que ce
n'était pas ce n'était pas le but de
manquer de respect et le soir je reçois
et c'était la première fois que je me
faisais insulter
on va venir tu vas voir on va taper
prévenu que terre mercenaire tu viens
que pour l'argent et enlever le compte
était alain morini-bosc sociale après
c'est comme moi je le dis souvent
personne te force à la télé la télé
c'est toi qui viens météo sur la
terrasse et on n'est pas je connais pas
quelqu'un qui vient chez toi
intox vient entend maintenant hâte et
les presser alors après il faut tout
prendre koh lanta quand ils font koh
lanta maintenant il faut peut-être se
dire je vais aller à koh lanta ça va
être une expérience extraordinaire
mais peut-être que derrière je me faire
démonter par dans l'est par les réseaux
sociaux c'est malheureux c'est que chez
kelly a même pas ce truc là mais moi je
me dis comme jean-mi je me dis voilà
voilà c'est ça